[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le 78 weekend
le magazine dédié à vos loisirs et à vos
sorties dans cette émission on parlera
pâtisserie avec Eva linora cette
pâtissière a remporté sa qualification
pour la finale du championnat de France
du dessert bonsoir bonsoir on vous
retrouve dans un instant juste avant on
va découvrir quelques idées de sortie
pour les vacances on commence tout de
suite avec le parc animalier de toiri
après 3 mois de fermeture hivernale il a
rouvert ses portes le weekend dernier et
il vous réserve quelques nouveautés un
reportage de Romain grabette et Patrick
Jacques de
Dixmude ces grenouilles semblent
inoffensives pourtant elles font partie
des espèces les plus dangereuses au
monde le poison d'un seul de ces
philobates terrible suffit pour tuer 10
humains ils viennent de rejoind indre
l'arche des petites bêtes du parc
animalier de Toir inauguré l'an dernier
les visiteurs pourront redécouvrir dans
cette arche le rat à trompe à l'odorat
extrêmement développé absent du parc
depuis un an et demi parmi les nouvelles
espèces certaines sont en voie
d'extinction il y a des programmes
européen d'élevage pour la conservation
des espèces menacées et quand on a les
installations optimum pour ces espèces
le coordinateur du programme nous prête
il nous confie les animaux et à ce
moment-là on peut les élevé et ce
coordinateur va décider où telle mâle ou
telle femelle va partir pour reproduire
dans tel parc où seront les dispatch et
les petits en fait il gère toute la
population captive au niveau européen
pour qu'elle soit pour éviter en fait
toute
consanguinité le parc de toirie a
accueilli des gekosenin turquoises dont
l'espèce est menacée ce lésard est de
plus en plus répandu comme animal
domestique ce qui rend sa reproduction
plus difficile ils ont été placés en
quarantaine dans le cadre de la
conservation de l'espèce seul quelques
visiteurs prenant un forfait d'entrée
spécifique auront l'opportunité de les
voir et à noter également la serre au
papillon de la queue les ivelines à
rouvert ce weekend après le zoau on
passe à la Bergerie nationale pendant
cette période de vacances scolaires les
activités pour les enfants sont
évidemment à l'honneur jusqu'au 2 mars
vous pouvez visiter la ferme sur le
thème du CIRC un reportage de Aurélia
debiss pendant les vacances d'hiver
place au cirque à la ferme la Erie
nationale à rambouiller propose tous les
après-midis différentes animations
autour des arts du cirque des parcours
d'acrobatie entre des bottes de paille
la fabrication de masques à partir de
peinture au jaune d'œuf ou encore des
tours de magie où l'on transforme la
crème en beurre au programme également
des numéros de dressage pas de tigrees
ni de lions mais des oies nos oies ont
l'avantage d'être élevé depuis tout
jeune parmi les chiens de bergers
puisque ce sont des oies qu'on utilise
pour rentraîner les chiot et donc elles
ont l'habitude de se faire un petit peu
malmener par les chiens et donc les
enfants on va dire que c'est un petit
peu les vacances pour elles et et du
coup il y a aucun il y a aucun souci à
ce niveau-là juste les
accompagner on faisait une ronde et on
et on devait mettre les Ies dans la
ronde et on se devait baisser et si
quelqu'un bougeait et benah il et ben
loi elle prend sa place et après elle
s'enfuit on a levé nos bras et les
devait passer en dessous mais il y en a
quelquesunes qui s'est
échappé en fin d'après-midi la visite
100 % nature se termine par la
découverte des soins aux animaux moutons
chèvres poules et vaches voilà de quoi
émerveiller nos petits apprentis
fermier et ce weekend vous pourrez
également assister à une compétition
internationale de modélisme ça se passe
au gymnase Maurice Baquet au clés
sous-bois vendredi samedi dimanche 3
jours durant lesquels les meilleurs
pilotes du monde s'affronteront lundi
Philippe guireud l'organisateur de cette
5e édition de l'i top comme s'appelle
cette compétition était l'invité du 78
sport je vous propose de regarder
ensemble un extrait tout d'abord comment
se décompose une épreuve de voltige
puisqu'on va assister à de la Volti ce
weekend bah c'est c'était une épreuve de
Volti imposé donc avec des figures
imposées avec différentes catégories
vous avez la promotion qui permet au aux
jeunes et moins jeunes d'ailleurs de de
se lancer dans cette compétition la
catégorie Nationale un peu plus
compliqué et finalement un CAT
international qui est pratiqué dans dans
l'Europe entière voir dans le monde
entier alors il y aura de nombreux
pilotes 63 pilotes présents ce weekend
au cl sous bois les meilleurs du monde
je vous propose de regarder un petit
extrait de l'édition précédente l'année
dernière pour voir un peu ce que ce à
quoi cela
[Musique]
ressemble
Philippe la moindre des choses que l'on
puisse dire c'est que c'est envoûtant
quand même he c'est un balai incroyable
non c'est très envoûtant et en fait là
ce que vous avez montré c'est en fait il
y a deux deux concours dans le dans
cette compétition il y a le concours de
Volti imposé et donc ce qu'on vient de
voir le concours de vol en musique qui
la différence alors entre les deux bah
le vol le vol en musique c'est des
vicures totalement librees le pilote
fait ce qu'il veut choisit sa musique et
cetera alors qu'en figure imposée bon
bah les figures sont imposées par la
Fédération aérienne internationale
qu'est-ce qu'on peut voir justement
comme figure imposée on pense tout de
suite peut-être au looping dans le
langage profane c'est des looping des
tonneaux des renversements une
combinaison des deux voire des trois on
arrive à des figures qui qui n'ont pas
vraiment de nom connu du grand public
très complexe quel est le le type
d'épreuve que vous préférez vous puisque
je sais que vous êtes aussi pilote à la
place de temps en temps organisateur
mais aussi pilote tout à fait oui mais
moi je ne fais que de l'imposer je fais
pas de libre en musique pour l'instant
alors on on voit un des exemplaires ici
sur la table du 78 sport ça pèse combien
là quelle est l'envergure et les
caractéristiques de de ce modèle là
c'est un peu le le le type d'avion qu'on
pourra voir ce weekend au clés sousbois
donc il fait 80 cm d'envergure 80 cm de
longueur et il fait 80 87 g exactement
en ord de vol avec la batterie c'est
ultra léger c'est très très léger ça
veut dire que ce genre d'avion ne peut
pas voler en extérieur c'est réservé
exclusivement aux démonstration indoor
ah oui oui ça en extérieur c'est c'est
carrément impossible le moindre souffle
d'air il part et pour vous donner un
petite idée quand on vole en gymnase on
coupe les chauffages du gymnase ah oui à
ce point-l alors quand on préparait
l'émission vous me parliez de de la
conception spécifique de de ces modèles
racontez-nous un petit peu de quoi c'est
fait en fait c'est fait de plaque de dé
pron qui est à l'origine fait pour faire
de l'isolation dans les maisons on est
un peu détourné de son usage premier
donc qui est ajouré et recouvert avec de
la feuille de Milard pour que ça soit le
plus léger possible c'est totalement
artisanal ça veut dire qu'on trouve pas
ça dans le dans le commerce si il existe
des kites dans le commerce mais qui sont
souvent beaucoup beaucoup plus lourds et
alors par rapport à la compétition on va
revenir à la compétition de ce weekend
il y a une spécificité je crois c'est le
vol 4D vous me disiez voilà à quoi ça
ressemble le vol 4D bah le vol 4D on en
a vu un petit peu au départ de du
reportage c'est principalement utilisé
dans le dans les figures libres ça
permet à l'avion de reculer donc c'est
ce qui est peut-être le plus
spectaculaire pour les téléspectateurs
s'il y a quelque chose à cocher ce
weekend voilà et et assez peu courant de
voir un avion reculer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi on va maintenant parler pâtisserie
nous avons la chance de recevoir Eva
linora une yinoise qui s'est qualifiée
mardi pour la finale du championnat de
France du dessert bonjour bonjour alors
un mot sur sur ce concours sur ce
championnat de France donc vous avez dû
en fait envoyer un dossier en décembre
dernier avec votre réalisation votre
création et une une photo votre dossier
a été sélectionné tout à fait mardi il
s'agissait donc de la sélection pour la
finale qui aura lieu en mars à Nice il y
a eu donc des concours de qualification
un peu partout en France h au total et
vous avez passé quant à vous celui de la
sélection Nord à orchie tout à fait
alors on va découvrir en image votre
votre création et vous allez nous
expliquer de quoi il s'agit alors ça
s'appelle fraîcheur givrée d'agrume et
d'exotisme alors bah il s'agit d'unun
tube en maringue
française à l'intérieur j'ai mis donc un
petit croustillant en noisette une
compotée compotée d'agrume un sorbet
youou un petit peu de chantiller et donc
dessus une fleur en mangue alors
pourquoi en fait ces ingrédients là plus
particulièrement ben j'ai juste essayé
de faire ce qui me plaisait enfin de
réunir IR dans dans mon dessert les
ingrédients qui qui me parlaient le plus
et qui que j'aimais donc voilà c'est
c'est un choix purement personnel mais
voilà c'est ça ça prend du temps vous
avez mis pas mal de de mois pour vous
entraîner alors il y a beaucoup de temps
sur
la le la mise au point du dessert savoir
la présentation comment associer les
différents éléments une bonne équilibre
des saveurs des goûts et puis une fois
que le dessert est calé la photo les
recettes c'est beaucoup d'entraînement
de répétition pour essayer de le sortir
en minimum de temps et que ça devienne
automatique et beaucoup d'automatisme à
gagné voilà alors vous travaillez à la
maison le nôtre à plaisir donc les chefs
pâtissiers de de cette maison vous ont
aidé dans dans la réalisation ah oui ben
je dois enfin le dessert de tient pas
qu'à moi donc c'est une une association
avec les chefs ils m'ont aidé sur
bah le le développement et puis après
beaucoup l'entraînement beaucoup de de
blanc le weekend le matin beaucoup
d'entraînement en dehors des heures de
de travail et voilà alors vous on aidé
aussi également pour la la technique
vous vous m'expliquiez pour préparer
cette émission que vous êtes venu avec
des petits ballons de vaudruche euh oui
donc donc sur le dessert il y a une une
petite bille en sucre donc c'est une
technique qu'on a mis au point avec un
un des chefs de chez le nôtre on est
parti d'une idée que on a eu en
discutant avec un ancien apprenti de
chez le nôtre et donc on cherchait à à
mettre au point une bille de suc dans
laquelle il y aurait un caramel liquide
et donc il en est venu cette idée de
petit ballon pour faire ma bille en
sucre et ensuite craquer le le ballon
pour voilà verser le ballon pour que la
B soit plus que la bille voilà alors une
autre difficulté c'était le tube en
meringue je crois euh oui donc là la
difficulté c'est qu'une meringue
classiquement se met elle se fait cuire
au four et ça a tendance un petit peu à
gonfler et à éclater donc moi il me
fallait quel quelque chose d'assez net
et donc on a une l'idée de la mettre la
faire cuire dans une étube et donc d'où
d'ù mes tubes en en meringue voilà alors
le le jury note le visuel le goût mais
pas que quels sont les critères
finalement pour plaire au
juris il faut l'association enfin un
jury travail donc qui note la technicité
du dessert les méthodes de travail la
propreté l'organisation
l'attitude du candidat aussi pour être
posé voilà et après un jury dégustation
donc qui not l'association texture le
goût l'assiette aussi donc pour ça j'ai
voulu travailler aussi sur une cloche
pour rappeler c'estess de rappeler des
éléments de mon dessert sur l'assiette
et voilà les principaux critères c'est
assez stressant j'imagine d'avoir ces
jury qui vous observent tout au long de
de on s un petit peu observé et bah
c'est surtout au départ en fait on les
voit ils tournent donc on se demande à
quelle sauce on va être un peu mangé et
après une fois qu'on est parti on fait
plus beaucoup attention au aux personnes
qui vous restez du coup concentré sur
votre recette un autre point également à
noter il faut que votre réalisation
finale colle exactement à la recette et
à la photo que vous avez envoyé dans le
dossier en décembre pas le droit à
l'improvisation finalement non bah c'est
par souci aussi d'équité entre les
différentes demi-finale parce qu'on
passe pas tous en même temps donc entre
les premiers et les derniers si on
respectéecte pas tous la photo qu'on a
envoyé c'est pas c'est pas juste donc
par souci d'équité alors on va parler
également un petit peu de de vous donc
vous avez 28 ans et finalement vous avez
commencé la pétierie il y a seulement 5
ans oui bah oui alors vous avez
auparavant fait un master de chimie
spécialisé dans les arômes alimentaires
donc ça reste une formation culinaire
mais bon c'est c'est assez loin
finalement d'un métier arti artisanal
pourquoi ce ce revirement finalement euh
benah en fait j'ai toujours bien aimé
étudier j'ai j'étais bien dans les
études ça m'intéressait de de continuer
mes études la chimie c'était quelque
chose qui me passionnait et en plus
étudier les arômes donc c'est pas commun
et pour ça ça m'a enfin c'était une voix
qui me plaisait après il y avait une
différence vraiment entre les études et
le travail et je me suis aperçu que
c'était pas vraiment ma voix donc bah
tout en restant dans ce domaine là j'ai
bifurqué sur un domaine qui me plaisait
plus et donc la pâtisserie et la
pâtisserie c'est ça a été votre choix
alors vous travaillez donc à la maison
le nôtre la petite anecdote c'est vous
avez commencé comme vendeuse là-bas mais
non pas en tant que paâtisière oui non
bah plusieurs moyens de rentrer dans la
maison moi c'était par la voie de la
vente et bah je regrette pas parce que
du coup ça me m'offre un éventail de
enfin j'ai vu plusieurs choses et puis
puis bah pour faire des gâteaux il faut
savoir aussi les Vendes donc ça me
permet aussi d'avoir une relation un peu
avec le client d'avoir vu comment
comment il réagissait enfin une autre
une autre vision du métier d'avoir du
coup le retour des consommateurs alors
la la suite maintenant c'est la finale
donc le 26 mars à Nice oui voilà vous
présenterez donc le même dessert c'est
c'est la règle et cette fois il y aura
une épreuve supplémentaire oui il y a un
panier garni donc qui est réalisé par le
président du jury donc donc Philippe
conticcini donc on sait pas ce qu'il y
aura dans le panier garni c'est la
surprise et avec les ingrédients qu'il
va nous préparer on devra faire 10
assiettes inventé donc du coup là cette
fois ça sera dein le jour de voilà créer
créer avoir une nouvelle création
finalement avec ce pan Garn mais en tout
cas on vous souhaite une une bonne
chance on espère P voir gagner cette
fameuse finale merci d'avoir été avec
nous sur ce plateau nous on va enchaîner
du coup avec d'autres reportages loisirs
je vous propose de découvrir tout de
suite en image laito un art martial
méconnu réunissant de nombreuses
techniques de combat il a été créé en
Polynésie il est aujourd'hui pratiqué
par une centaine d'ivelinois et la
discipline tend à s'ouvrir au plus grand
nombre par le self défense reportage à
morpa d'Antony res et Jonathan Vman
garder son calme parler avant d'agir et
se défendre en cas d'insistance de
l'agresseur ce sont les trois règles de
l'ITO une discipline de self défense qui
s'inspire de tous les arts martiaux pour
les combattants confi la partie sportive
va vraiment les intéresser parce que
nous avons toutes les dimensions nous
avons chez nous beaucoup de d'anciens JB
judo kickboxing qui veulent voir toutes
les dimensions du combat ça c'est un
gros intérêt pour eux et ils peuvent
conserver bien sûr leur origine et leur
savoir-faire d'abord réservé aux
professionnels de la sûreté et de la
sécurité les pratiquants d'O arrivent
désormais sur le tatami pour élargir
leur palette technique de combattant en
cas d'agression comme Denis venu aux
arts martiaux par le taendo et laikido
la S défense qu'on pratique ici ça
permet vraiment spontanément d'avoir des
bases solides le fait de connaître une
palette technique savoir se comporter
c'est vrai que c'est des situations
qu'on peut quand même rencontrer dans
dans le quotidien quoi créé en Polynésie
l'ITO signifie guerrier c'est archétype
du perfectionnement de soie traditionnel
dans les arts martiaux associe également
la modernité du cadre de la légitime
défense défin par la loi on va prendre
l'article 1225 du code pénal sur la
légitime défense et on va leur rabâer le
rabach chez nos élèves pour qu'ils
comprennent que sur la voie martiale
dans laass défense il y a l'avant la
préparation la connaissance de la loi
pendant si on se fait agresser que faire
et après les tout ce qui va être sur le
judiciaire et le pénal quatre club
accueille une centaine d'adhérents dans
les
Yvelines pour la 3e saison Saint-Quentin
en Yveline lance pulsation urbaine une
programmation autour des cultures
urbaines elle est consacrée cette année
au 30 ans du Hipop sur le territoire et
pour l'occasion le musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin en yeline lui dédie une
exposition et donne la parole au street
artist du territoire un reportage de
oréliia debici et Elod
[Applaudissements]
moine pour sa 23e édition du
semi-marathon le Lyon club
blancur
1984 il y a 30 ans déjà la mythique
compagnie de danse hip hop et Black
blomber faisaient leur premier pas à 5
en isline territoire qui fut l'un des
berceaux du genre en France célèbre tout
au long de l'année cet anniversaire au
travers de différents rendez-vous parmi
ceux à ne pas manquer notons que le
musée de la ville présente jusqu'au 28
juin une nouvelle exposition baptisée
street culture Sky elle s'intéresse
naturellement au hiphop mais plus
largement aux cultures urbaines skate
danse et Graf notamment cette culture là
est une culture importante sur le
territoire pas seulement à 50 ans en
Eveline mais c'est une culture qui est
souvent pas assez reconnue et elle
mérite qu'on en parle mais c'est ai
aussi une culture qui a des valeurs
vraiment propres qui sont importantes et
revendiquer à la fois de se débrouiller
soi-même mais aussi du respect de
l'autre de la valeur par la compétence
et pas par par ce qu'on est ou par la
valeur sociale c'est des choses qui sont
très importantes pour les hipopers c'est
qu'on a voulu traduire dans cette
exposition une rétrospective à travers
laquelle le musée donne la parole au
street artistes du territoire qui ont
accepté de témoigner de leur univers de
création chacun a apporté son idée en
fait moi j'ai travaillé surtout dans le
groupe du skets
on a partagé nos vidéos beaucoup de
clichés les lieux où on aime bien se
retrouver qu'on appelle les spots et
après en fonction des autres contacts
ils ont apporté le leur univers à eux
soit le monde du rap soit le monde du
grap et pareil soit leur spot soit leur
façon de filmer objet texte vidéo et
objet d'époque ponctue la visite une
occasion de s'interroger sur l'évolution
de ces cultures je pense que c'est quand
même peu plus accessible pour tous
beaucoup qui en vivent maintenant je
pense de ce soit du Graf de la danse ou
autre mais de pouvoir toucher à ce monde
là en fait des maines qui était un petit
peu à l'époque un peu
ghetto un petit peu un aspect un peu
négatif et je pense que maintenant ça a
complètement changé ça c'est beaucoup
ouvert il y a beaucoup de Battles qui
sont
organisés le skate on le voit partout il
y a un comb du skate le grap il y en a
qui sont devenus maintenant des artistes
très connus donc c'est vrai pense
largement évoluer les codes
vestimentaires ont évolué aussi soit
dans les skateurs ou les danseurs
complètement changé pour s'intier à ces
pratiques trois ateliers pochoir Graf et
glisse animés par des professionnels
seront présentés de mars à
avril une librairie solidaire vient
d'ouvrir au profit d'action humanitaire
à Chevreuse une librairie qui récupère
vos livres et les revend à prè réduit
Wilfred Richi et
elodan des livres à Bacou allant de 1 à
5 € l'ONG bibliothèque sans frontières a
ouvert une librairie solidaire à
l'espace culturel de saintrémille et
chevreuses c'est également un point de
collecte où les gens peuvent déposer
leurs livres les livres sont triés une
partie des livres sont destinés à la
librairie solidaire une autre partie est
destinée au local de BSF qui est à épone
et une autre partie va à la récupération
papier parce qu'ils sont pas
récupérables ni dans un lieu ni dans un
autre les bénéfices sont reversés au
profit de projets qui favorisent l'accès
au plus grand nombre à l'éducation et à
l'information aujourd'hui on intervient
dans une vingtaine de pays dont la
France et on intervient auprès de
partenaires à l'étranger pour les
appuyer sur des projets autour de
l'accès à la culture qui peuvent être
des bibliothèques des centres culturels
en France on intervient auprès de public
instiuation de précarité notamment on
intervient dans des centres d'accueil et
d'hébergement où on a créé des espaces
bibliothèques avec des animations de
médiation autour du livre bibliothèque
sans frontière dispose d'une base
logistique à éepone et plus de 20 points
de collecte en région parisienne des
antennes devraient ouvrir prochainement
à Lille ou à Lyon 500 bénévoles dans le
monde participent à ce
projet 78 langues régionales sont
connues en France et une Charte
européenne des langues régionales vient
d'être présentée les Yvelines elles
aussi ont leur langu elle il existe un
patoi qui date du 19e siècle nous vous
racontons son histoire avec Antony
Resche et Jonathan
villman il était un temps où certains
ivelinois parlaient une autre langue
au-delà des souvenirs il ne reste plus
que quelques rares documents comme cette
monographie de
1898 à l'époque le ministre de
l'Éducation nationale commande à ses
instituteurs des études communales en
vue de l'exposition universelle de Paris
entre la partie géographique et
historique monsieur Belhomme maître
d'école à folinville petit village
yvelinois de 776 âes semble étonné par
le PI moi apparemment les habitants
déformment en fait beaucoup de mots et
là il explique par exemple que la lettre
A est prononcée avec le son de la lettre
O on dit une pote une taaube une rve et
cetera qui ressemble
beaucoup à un vieux français en fait à
une une façon ancienne de parler le
français avec des des des y à la place
de ha avec des accents plus aigus que
graves au milieu du 19e siècle la ville
de mantla jolie compte environ 3500
habitants le chemin de fer ne traverse
pas encore la commune mais le parl
populaire y est bien installé au grand
désarrois du sous-préfet Armand Cassan
qui rédige un ouvrage consacré à la
ville en 1800 33 il porte un jugement
assez assez sévère sur sur ses
particularités locales qui qu'il décrit
comme autant de VI hein c'est des
expressions assez fortes qu' l'emploit
d'expressions corrompues encore des
termes assez fort il va même jusqu'à
parler de de barbarisme de l'ignorance
depuis cet autre temps ces intonations
semblent avoir disparu le beta est
redevenu le bétail l'ancov l'alcove le
Manoi ne fera donc pas partie des
langues régionales reconnu par la Charte
européenne charte que l'État doit encore
adopter et avant de se quitter un coup
d'œil à l'agenda on en parlait dans
cette émission jusqu'à dimanche se tient
l' top la compétition internationale de
modélisme des clés sous boois 15 nations
65 pilotes rendez-vous au gymnase
Maurice BAQUEY pour des shows aériens et
des vols en musique ce weekend c'est
également le retour du festival du
cirque l'un des plus renommés d'Île-de-
France des représentations samedi et
dimanche avec jongleur acrobate
voltigeur clown et funambule ça se passe
au parc du sauttoir au
Murau c'est la fin de cette émission
merci d'avoir été avec nous je vous
souhaite un très bon
[Applaudissements]
weekend